coming up tomorrow on CBS mornings our
conversation with award-winning actor
that's Michael B Jordan the Black
Panther star stepping behind the camera
to make his directing debut for the
movie Creed 3. he also by the way stars
in the film here's some of what he had
to say about that
you're directing and you're starring in
the movie you're giving directions I
understand you have your mouth guard in
yes yes yes and then and I can't
it was uh frustrating at points but then
they started to understand the like my
my voice with the mouth guard in but
then also physical Direction you know
one of the cheat codes that I've learned
from Bradley Cooper and John Favreau who
have both you know acted and directed
you know themselves in in projects is
the superpower to be able to direct
while you act so you're able to you know
if I wanted you to you know to turn your
body you know to you know to your to
your right I would just start stepping
that way in my performance and I'll get
the shot that I need you know watching
while you're while you're shooting you
find little things that you can do to
influence a shot without breaking the
moment and calling cut and going back to
your actor and talking to them you can
actually get that from them in in the
moment much
I thought his process was very
interesting he was talking about Creed
but he was in town because he's working
on something really big off the court
that's what we're really talking about
more on that conversation tomorrow with
a great Michael B Jordan we'll see you
tomorrow right here at the table take it
easy